how much have you pulled aside justin  and vin have been like so tell me  everything about fast tent  i have definitely asked some questions  about 10 and 11  and um it it has been confirmed  that we are going to shoot back to back  and get both in the can  um which  is interesting um  and um  i'm hearing that we're going to touch a  lot of continents  between the two i cannot say  where but a lot  and i think  the higher-ups that are involved in this  franchise  are specifically aware of the die-hard  fans and supporters around the world  and we all carry a particular torch  of responsibility in knowing that there  is a beast and we got to feed that beast  and give them  what they want what they love and what  they're used to